hey everybody what's going on seeker lab
just made the announcement of the
all-new titan evo 2022 chair we've
actually had it in the geek culture
studios for the past couple weeks here
are my thoughts on it first off this is
an evolution not a revolution it is a
combination of the titan and the omega
in terms of size it's a size in between
but the design is relatively the same
but the pu 2.0 leather feels more like
genuine leather than before we've got
gel padded armrests that are magnetic
attached also this pillow in the back or
headrest is magnetic now as well mom no
straps i'm loving it we've got dual
lumbar support in the back so my back
feels really good and you can also lean
way way back i can't do it because i'll
be out of camera but trust me you can
actually go to sleep on this chair and
it's just overall really well built and
the new softweep is stunning absolutely
amazing anyway check it out
seekerlab.co we're loving our new chair
right zacky hell yeah
yeah
we
it turns